High Noon In The Northern Ireland
assembly a last-ditch effort to elect a
speaker and former power sharing
government with the deadline looming and
no executive in place outgoing first
Minister designate Shin fein's Michelle
O'Neill blamed the dup
ER Jeffrey Donaldson and the dup have
left us all at the mercy of the
heartless and dysfunctional Tory
government whose own Survival is all
that ever counts the Tories careless for
the consequences of their dire policy
decisions under political choices on the
lives of workers and families here the
unionists won't restore Devolution
unless the brexit protocol is scrapped
and that's a problem for Rishi sunak the
time for talking
is over
the Prime Minister on his first day in
office said this
I want to unite this nation not just
with words but by actions and what we
are looking for now is the action to
resolve the problems with the protocol
and to restore northland's place within
the United Kingdom
to avoid a brexit border between
Northern Ireland and the Republic the
protocol established an Irish Sea border
instead the dup wanted axed but the new
prime minister doesn't want to trade war
with the European Union and that's left
Northern Ireland in political stalemate
at the worst possible moment prompting
angry exchanges in the chamber
I will take no lectures from the dup
when it comes to issues of respect
I'm ashamed of this place
because unlike others in this chamber
I'm capable of Shame there's an awful
lot of anger in here today and I can
understand that but I have to say the
anger that was being shown in this floor
today is absolutely nothing compared to
the anger that is out on the streets
there's the political theater at
Stormont and there's the reality for
those dealing with the cost of living
and energy crisis at this food pantry
for lower income families in County Arma
they're seriously concerned about what
winter holds for people this is the
first year that I've went out and
actually bought a stock of blankets and
hot water bottles and hooded blankets
and that we can keep people warm this
winter it pains me to say I do think
there might be people who will die this
year because they don't know where to go
and get help unless there's compromise
it's difficult to see what another
election costing six and a half million
pounds will achieve because the protocol
problem will still exist on the other
side of it so they still won't be able
to form a government
it's supposed to be the Cornerstone of
the Good Friday agreement but Stormont
remains a place of in out politics David
Levin's Sky News in Belfast